these are the youngest journalists in
the city of firozabad they're working on
the next edition of their unique
magazine
balvani bacho kiawaz or the voice of
children is a magazine by and for young
people about child labour and their
rights
the stories that we write for the
magazine are all related to children and
inform readers about the reality of our
town when we share these stories with
government officials it helps them
understand the difficulties that
children face
fourteen-year-old harmony has been
contributing to the magazine for two
years she lives in an impoverished area
of firozabad where entire families are
employed in the glass bangles industry
she convinced one neighbor to stop her
three daughters aged between nine and
twelve from working and send them to
school instead
we have five children and no one to help
us so when we were in financial
difficulty we asked the children to work
a lot of children here work and at home
our children started helping us when we
were going through a rough patch
sarita devi sent her children back to
school when her husband recovered from
an illness and could work again but not
everyone would do the same
feruzabad's glass bangles industry is
200 years old and the factories are
known for their poor working conditions
generations of families have been
employed in the trade although many work
from home
when we walk through these narrow lanes
of firozabad we can see many children
making bangles rights groups say school
closures because of coronavirus and then
an outbreak of dengue fever mean more
children are forced to work because they
don't have access to online learning
this home children as young as six sit
in front of small flames using the heat
to join broken glass bangles they do
this for up to eight hours a day child
labor is illegal in india but rights
groups say it's difficult to stop those
working at home we had child labor 10
million in 2011 i'm doubling it only and
primarily because of covet as well so i
think what we can say coronavirus has
been impacting the world over but in
india the issues that we always had have
amplified to an extent which is actually
quite scary
the release of this year's voice of
children magazine has been delayed due
to lockdowns but harmony and her team
are now pushing the final touches on the
issue knowing their work has never been
more important
elizabeth puranam al jazeera ferozabad
uttar pradesh